السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته وعليكم
السلام ورحمه
الله الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
اشهد ان
محمد رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله وزيل
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلا هادي
له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صلى الله
عليه
وسلم
الله ask
fors and cons
ofs gu
[Silence]
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم وشر الامور
محدثاتها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في
النار
الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏relig and
religious aid and guidance is in the
fire myar brothers and
sisters we are inherently social
beings from the moment we are bn we find
ourselves surrounded by a community that
cares for us shares our joys supps us
‏ent interaction and conne
our
comm
indiv others
‏crucial for famili to not distract
children videoes
inter matal
things can
create
parents own fam
[Silence]
‏as them
as and edate them
slowly things
to appreciate
them they always have follow thees as
[Silence]
‏careful not trust telling do
things acc
‏all and most the family so do not break
it we have to have qu time family
applying islam to
ourselves if we fail to show them the
right way they will follow what their
they will follow their close
friends
which cann be always the right pa
[Silence]
‏cheng الله سبحانه
وتعالى قران
[Silence]
الله
we we
[Silence]
محد صل عليه
وسم
حث
اس
as so blessed are those strangers
ح make us like
[Silence]
الله الله
‏hearts
[Silence]
خلقنا الله سبحانه وتعالى بطبيعه
اجتماعيه فمنذ ولادتنا نجد انفسنا محاطين
بجماعه تهتم بنا وتفرح لفرحنا وتساد دنا
في اوقات
الحزن مشاعرنا تتفاعل مع تفاعلات هذه
الجماعه وتهتم بنا
عندما يكون هناك عندما يكون هناك نقص في
التفاعل في الاسره او المجتمع المباشر
يبحث الافراد وخاصه الاطفال عن مجتمعات
اخرى يشعرون فيها بانهم مفهوم
ومقدر من المهم الا يشغل الاهالي اطفالهم
بالالعاب الالكترونيه والماديات والانترنت
فهذا يمكن ان يخلق شعورا بالاغتراب بين
الاباء
والاطفال مما يجعل الاطفال يشعرون بالبعد
عن
عائلاتهم وعندما نقول لهم صلوا ونحن لا
نصلي او صوموا ونحن لا نصوم ولا يرون
تاثير الصلاه والصيام مع على تعاملنا مع
الناس ومعهم فسن اخسر ثقتهم
ونخسر والثقه هي اهم عامل بين كل العلاقات
واهمها الاسره
العبوا معهم تواصلوا معهم وانظر كثير من
الوقت معهم ودائما عليك وعليهم اتباع
القوانين
والشرع في صحيح البخاري عن ابي هريره رضي
الله عنه قال صلى الله عليه وسلم قال قال
صلى الله عليه وسلم انما بعثت لاتمم مكارم
الاخلاق فاذا لم يجدوا من يحتوي فطرتهم
السليمه بالاخلاق
الحميده وكما نعلم قد يبحث قد يبحثون
حينها عن من يفهمهم بصحبه خارج المنزل مما
قد يؤدي بهم في الكثير من الاحيان الى
الضلال الا من رحم الله كمسلمين من واجبنا
تطبيق الاسلام بشكل صحيح واظهار ذلك
لاطفالنا في بيوتنا بالفعل وليس فقط
بالكلام بان نكون خير مثال
لاطفالنا اذا لم نرشم الى الطريق الصحيح
فسيت ابعون ما يفعله اصدقائهم المقربون
وقد لا يكون ذلك دائما متوافقا مع مع
المبادئ
الاسلاميه هذا تحد في عالمنا
اليوم حيث يكون حيث يمكن ان يشعر المرء
بالعزله عند التمسك بالطريق الصحيح يحذرنا
الله سبحانه وتعالى بقوله وان تطع اكثر من
في الارض يضلوك عن سبيل الله ان يتبعون
الا الظن وان هم الا
يخرصون تذكرنا هذه الايه انه ليس كل ما هو
شائع او مقبول في نطاق واسع يكون صوابا
يجب ان يكون يجب ان نكون يقظين ومميزين في
خياراتنا وما نسمح لاطفالنا باتباعه وايضا
تذكير لاولويات
قال صلى الله عليه وسلم بدا الاسلام غريبا
وسيعود غريبا كما بدا فطوبى
للغرباء يوضح هذا الحديث ان البقاء على
الدين
يمكن ان يجعلنا نشعر كالغرباء ولكن الجزاء
كبير مقابل الحفاظ على
اخلاصنا لله در الفضل بن
عياض
بحكمه قائلا اتبع طريق الهدى ولا يضرك قله
السالكين واياك وطرق الضلاله ولا تغتر
بكثره
الهالكين ايها الاخوه والاخوات تذكروا
اهميه روابطنا
الاجتماعيه والدور الكبير الذي نلعبه في
توجيه اطفالنا ولا ندع انشغالات الدنيا
تلهيهم عن الطريق الصحيح ولا تلهينا
ايضا ونجس تعاليم الاسلام ونكون افضل مثال
لاطفالنا فانهم هم الحاملون لهذا الدين
بعدنا وانها
لمسؤول نال الله العديل
القدير ان
يجعلنا كفؤ لحمل هذه
المسؤوليه اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي
ولكم فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله حمد
الشاكرين الحمد لله في كل وقت وحين وصلاه
وسلاما على خاتم خاتم الانبياء
والمرسلين عليه و اله واصحابه افضل الصلاه
واتم
التسليم عم ضي الله
عنه رضي الله
[Silence]
الله
‏is open to those who seek it with
sincerity and
dation life has
two cr
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى سمان عليه السلام
سليمان عليه
السلام نعم الملك ملك
سليمان سليمان عليه
السلام المللك
سليمان سليمان
سبحان الله
والله
والله سليمان
[Silence]
‏hand
only
those
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
سبحان
الله
الله عم رضي الله
عنه الله
الله make me among the
people the people of your
serv
الله
الله and your
children be against you in the day of
judgment
يوم يفر المرء من اخيه وامه وابي وصاحبته
وبنيه
رحمن سبحانه وتعالى اخوتي في الله يمشي
سيدنا عمر رضي الله عنه في السوق يسمع احد
يدعو ويقول اللهم اجعلني من عبادك القليل
فيقول له رضي الله
عنه من اين اتيت بهذا
الدعاء
فيقول من قوله تعالى وقليل من عبادي
الشكور القرب من الله ورضاه يستحقان ان
نبذل الجهد والنفس فليس بالامر الهين ان
نكون من عباد الله المخلصين الطريق الى
الله ليس
مزدحما بل هو مفتوح لمن يسعى اليه بصدق
واخلاص فالحياه طريقان احدهما مزدحم في
الناس يتقاتلون من اجل حفنه من التراب
والاخر فارغ الا من قله يسعون الى كنوز لا
حصر
لها القله من عباد الله هم الشاكرون مهما
كان حالهم الملتزمون باوامر الله وقد وقد
بكى سيدنا عمر رضي الله عنه عندما ادرك
قول الرجل وقال كل نفس افقه منك يا عمر
اللهم اجعلني من عبادك
القليل ث ثم
اعلموا ان الله سبحانه وتعالى امركم بامر
فبدا فيه بنفسه فقال جل من
قال ان الله وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا
ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا تسليما
اللهم صل وسلم على عبدك ورسولك
محمد السراج المنير ورضى اللهم عن الاربعه
الخلفاء الراشدين المهديين ابي بكر وعمر
وعثمان وعلي وعن بقيه الصحابه وعن
التابعين وعن تابع التابعين ومن اتبعهم
باحسان الى يوم الدين وعنا معهم بعفوك
وكرمك واحسانك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واذل الشرك والمشركين ودمر اعداءك اعداء
الدين اللهم ادفع عنا القلاء والرياء
والربا والزنا والزلازل والمحن وسوء الفتن
ما ظهر منها وما
بطن وعن سائر بلاد المسلمين عامه يا رب
العالمين اللهم ثبتنا على قولك الثابت في
الحياه الدنيا والاخره ربنا لا تزق قلوبنا
بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك رحمه وانك
انت انك انت
الوهاب ربنا لا تؤخذنا ان نسينا او اخطانا
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اصرا كما حملته على
الذين من قبلنا ربنا ولا تحملنا ما لا
طاقه لنا به واعف عنا واغفر لنا وارحمنا
انت مولانا فانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
ربنا لا تزغ قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا
من لدنك رحمه انك انت الوهاب واصلح اللهم
احوالنا في الامور كلها وبلغنا ما
يرضيك ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون واوفوا
بعهد الله واوفوا بعهد الله اذا عاهدتم
ولا تنقض الايمان بعد توكيدها وقد جعلتم
الله عليكم كفيلا ان الله يعلم ان الله
يعلم وانتم لا تعلمون ان الله يعلم ما
تفعلون واذكروا الله العظيم الجليل يذكركم
واشكروه على نعمه يزدكم ولذكر الله اكبر
والله يعلم ما تصنعون واقم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان محم